the oldest and strongest emotion of
mankind is fear and the oldest and
strongest kind of fear is fear of the
unknown
HP Lovecraft eyes are yet to open fear
beyond blood these were the words spoken
between master Willem and Lawrence from
the cautious teacher to the ambitious
student fear what you do not understand
fear the old blood and so our story
begins as you might have guessed with
blood ancient blood deep below the city
of yharnam lies the ancient underground
labyrinth of tomorrow you know it as the
chalice dungeons the old labyrinth was
carved out by the to Marion's superhuman
beings that are said to have discovered
as sinister truth the hunters had
another name for the labyrinth they
called it the tomb of the gods for below
they found traces of godlike beings
named the great ones the great ones
could function on transcendental planes
of thought meaning they had elevated
their consciousness beyond the physical
realm the benefits of operating on this
plane are unclear perhaps it was in the
name of immortality or perhaps power as
even beyond the great ones could
interfere with beings and events in the
waking world whatever the case it is
clear that some sort of ascension took
place as there are numerous references
to some great ones being left behind
of all the strange life-forms that
reside in the nooks and crannies of the
old labyrinth the slugs are clear signs
of the left-behind great ones one such
great one appears to be abandoned debris
tiss a left behind being who apparently
did not ascend with her brethren one day
the brightest would be discovered by the
humans above in a crusade that begins
with a character named willem Master
Willem presided over a prestigious place
of learning
situated by a tranquil lake and secluded
within a gigantic forest bergen worth
housed the minds that would change the
world in fact everything sacred in
yharnam came to be traced back to bergen
worth including the most influential
characters within our story blood-borne
slaw is very character-driven
and there are five who are going to help
you become familiar with there was
master willem rune Smith Carol Lawrence
Michael ash and Gherman I'll introduce
them to you in the order that they
become relevant in the story as I said
master willem was the head of the school
at Bergen worth the man was obsessed
with the truth and believed in pushing
the limits of humanity in almost every
dialogue in description
Willem is referred to as master or
Provost clearly deserving of a great
deal of respect
many would eventually diverge from his
tutor äj-- but few can say that they
didn't owe everything to his research
for while Willem presided over Bergen
worth the scholars there discovered
terrific things in the tombs below the
city of yharnam once a group of young
Bergen Worth scholars discovered a holy
medium deep within the tomb this led to
the founding of the healing church and
the establishment of blood healing it's
hard to be sure exactly what was found
but we do know it was related to the
great ones on the ground floor of Bergen
Worth College we find the pearl slugs
remnants of the great ones and at the
very top of the college we find the
empty phantasm shell an empty
invertebrate shell that is said to be
the familiar of a great one after this
discovery whatever it was that showed
them that the great ones existed the
Bergen worth scholars launched an
inquiry into the great ones and the old
blood for from this point onwards there
is an explosion of law and history and
references to what the scholars found in
the tombs below yharnam many of these
references come from rune smith carroll
ii character of our story carroll
transcribed the inhuman utterings of the
great ones into what we now call carroll
runes in true love crafty and fashion it
is really likely that it's impossible
for humans
to comprehend the speech of the great
ones but carol apparently had a knack a
talent for creating a visual
representation of the great ones words
the hunter who receives this workshop
tool can etch carol runes into their
mind to attain their wondrous strength
provost willem would have been proud of
Carroll's runes
as they do not rely upon blood in any
measure this statement is curious it
tells us three things first
Provost Willem and Carol were close as
Willem would have been proud of him and
second Willem didn't have a chance to be
proud so it's possible that the two lost
contact and thirdly and most importantly
Willem would have been proud because the
runes did not rely on blood in other
words Willem did not approve the use of
the old blood the blood found in the
tomb of the gods the metamorphosis
ruined States the discovery of blood
made their dream of evolution a reality
metamorphosis and the excesses and
deviation that followed was only the
beginning
willem believed in a different path he
believed in attaining more insight for
humanity's eyes had yet to open the eye
roon states that master willem looked to
beings from higher planes for guidance
and sought to line his brain with eyes
in order to elevate his thoughts and
with these descriptions you should have
some idea of the scale of ambition of
these characters with the discovery of
beings greater than them came a desire
to ascend into godhood to push humanity
into its next stage of evolution the
only question was how blood or insight
and this was a question that split the
ranks of the Bergen worth scholars it's
how we arrived at the cutscene we
started out earlier with master willem
and lawrence parting ways master willem
I've come to bid you farewell
oh I know I know you think now to betray
me from this cutscene we can infer that
Lawrence was a high-ranking student of
Master Willem because firstly Lawrence
refers to Willem as master and secondly
we'll and clearly regards Lawrence
highly enough to call this departure a
betrayal no but you will never listen
Lawrence disagrees he does not see it as
the trail and here we come to the heart
of what their disagreement is about
essentially it boils down to the
difference between the two resources in
the game Willem believes man requires
insight and knowledge to ascend Lawrence
believes in the power of blood
Lawrence attempts to reassure Willem
telling him he will always fear the old
blood but that this fear will not stop
him using it I tell you I will not
forget our adage we are born of the
blood may men by the blood undone by
our eyes are yet to open fear beyond
blood I must take my leave
Lawrence leaves the Bergen Worth
scholars presumably with a small group
of rebels and goes on to found the
healing church Willem remains at Bergen
worth and attempts to elevate his
thoughts to a higher plane he will
return to our story at a later time so
while I tell you of what Lawrence went
on to do imagine Willem here in Bergen
worth sitting in his rocking chair over
the lake
musing on how to acquire insight and
elevate his thoughts to a higher plane
everything Lawrence would come to
achieve was based on the knowledge he
had come by in Bergen worth in
retrospect we clearly see why Willem saw
Lawrence's departure as a betrayal
perhaps Willem himself even planted
these ideas in Lawrence's mind and note
in the lecture hall reads master willem
was right evolution without courage will
be the ruin of our race Lawrence had
courage but it is likely that his
courage bordered on arrogance the bogan
Wirth student uniform states the healing
Church has its roots in Bergen Worth and
naturally borrows heavily from its
uniform design the focus not on
knowledge or thought but on pure
pretension would surely bring Master
Willem to despair if only he knew so
Lawrence threw caution to the wind and
put his faith in the old blood think on
human history imagine if in any era a
church was founded that had access to a
substance that could cure any illness
imagine if this church gave it freely to
a city how powerful that city would
become and how powerful the church would
become within it this is exactly what
happened in yharnam people came far and
wide to be treated with the miraculous
blood of the gods and the people of
yharnam put their faith in the healing
church in fact what happened in yharnam
is eerily similar to what happened in
the tombs deep below where the blood was
originally found and as you know many
chalice dungeons especially those of
Laurent
are now overrun by horrific beasts the
lower Leron chalice states there are
trace remains of medical procedures in
parts of ailing laron whether these were
attempts to control the scourge of the
beast or the cause of the outbreak is
unknown the ailing Laurent chalice
states the tragedy that struck this
ailing land of laron is said to have its
root in the scourge of the beasts some
have made the dreaded extrapolation that
yharnam may be next Yanam was next
through overuse of the healing blood the
city would eventually succumb to the
scourge of the Beast until then though
Lawrence and the healing Church managed
to grow in power with the miraculous
healing properties of their special yet
infected blood yharnam grows to become a
city of worship and fear as you explore
throughout the city you see the
influence of the church everywhere with
the anims resources lawrence clearly had
the power to grow the church beyond what
would have been possible at bergen worth
all the while he continued exploring the
labyrinth below yharnam the tomb
prospector said reads a tire of the tomb
prospectors who explore the old
labyrinth on behalf of the healing
church the healing church traces its
roots to Bergen worth and is therefore
aware of the ruins true importance these
ruins contain much more than hunted
trinkets indeed they hide the very
secrets of the old great ones
sought-after by those with the insight
to imagine greatness on top of this
Lawrence split the church into multiple
branches each with a different purpose
there was the choir the school of mensis
and the workshop we'll get to these
branches as they become appropriate but
the main purpose of the church at least
to the people of yharnam was the
administration of blood healing within
the grand cathedral itself lies a note
that says heir to the ritual of blood
purveyor of ministration place your hand
upon the altars sacred covering and
inscribe Master Lawrence's adage upon
your flesh blood ministers would have
been those who administered the blood
healing how else would the people of
Yanam be so obsessed with blood in
yharnam they produced more blood than
alcohol
as the former is more intoxicating
however the ministration of blood was
likely a means to an end for the healing
church still intended to commune with
the great ones in hopes of ascending
humanity to a higher plane this task was
given to the choir a group who were a
part of the healing church members of
the choir are both the highest-ranking
clerics of the healing church and
scholars who continued the work that
began at Bergen worth the I covering
indicates their debt to the teachings of
Master Willem even though their paths
diverged the choir garbed in black and
white with the familiar i covering
occupied at the upper cathedral ward it
seems to have been their job to research
and make contact with the great ones the
great is chalice became the cornerstone
of the choir the elite delegation of the
healing church it was also the first
great chalice brought back to the
surface since the time of Bergen worth
and allowed the choir to have audience
with the brightest a brightest was the
left behind great one who came to reside
below the grand Cathedral we are told
that the grand cathedral is the
birthplace of the healing churches
special blood and if the church were
indeed using the blood of the great ones
that who's to say it wasn't a brito sirs
blood the order of a brightest is one of
the secret rites of the choir used by
the high-ranking members of the healing
church use phantasms the invertebrates
known to be augers of the great ones to
partially summon abandoned debris tiss
one of the few rites that allow one to
directly utilize the power of the great
ones and evidence that the choir had
approached the eldritch truth the ogre
of a brightest is an arcane method of
fighting that was actually shared with
the second subsection of the healing
church the school of mensis the upper
echelon of the healing church are formed
by the school of mensis based in the
unseen village this brings us to our
next important character Michael ash who
was likely the head of the school of
mensis the school of mensis
was as the name implies a place of
learning research and experimentation
for the healing church their students
set reads the healing church has its
roots in Bougainville
and naturally borrows heavily from its
uniform design the school was based
below yharnam in a place called aha goo
the unseen village clearly the work of
menses was intended to be kept a secret
from the people of yharnam in fact as
time went on the school increasingly
seems to have been working alone even
separately from the healing church
itself the yah-ha ghoul attire tells us
the hunters of yaja goo answer to the
villagers founders the school of mensis
hunters in name only these kidnappers
blend into the night wearing this attire
these were not true hunters that title
was saved for the third subsection of
the healing church the hunters of the
workshop these capable warriors of the
church appeared as the scourge of the
beasts began to show in yharnam the
workshop hunters served under gurmann
the first hunter who you're all familiar
with the hunter attire reads one of the
standard articles of Hunter attire
fashioned at the workshop a fine piece
of Hunter attire that provides stable
defense to anyone facing yarns beastly
threat allows one to stalk beasts
unannounced by cover of night it's
possible the unannounced part of that
sentence is to do with killing beasts
without them noticing you but it could
also be because the workshop was a
secret institution the original workshop
is located in a very hard-to-find part
of cathedral ward and think about it you
don't want the town's folk believing
that the blood is turning them into
beasts when that information is floating
around you want to avoid panic at all
costs so the hunters hunted beasts under
the cover of night but the hunters and
the beastly scourge couldn't stay a
secret forever in what would come to be
called old yharnam a new disease
appeared it was called ashen blood I
call it a disease but the small medicine
on tablets used to treat it actually
counteract poison a tablet used to treat
ashen blood the baffling sickness that
ravaged old yharnam long ago these
tablets only provide short-term early
the ashen blood ailment eventually
triggered the spread of the beastly
scourge think about that we know that
the old blood heals every illness we
know that the old blood causes the
beastly scourge and we now know that the
ashen blood caused the beastly scourge
to spread in short it seems like people
were infected with the ashen blood and
the medicine that they had only provided
short-term relief and they were forced
to imbibe the old blood instead it's
even possible that the healing Church
used this ashen blood to gain power
swooping in with this miracle cure and
liberating the people from the ashen
blood disease since ashen blood seems
poisonous in nature perhaps the church
even poisoned the populace just for that
excuse to use the old blood because that
excuse to get the populace to believe in
you that would have been so powerful but
whatever the case the beastly scourge
was triggered overwhelmingly in old
yharnam we know that much to the point
where they actually had to burn it down
and cordon off old yharnam from the rest
of the city the red moon hangs low and
beasts ruled the streets we left no
other choice than to burn it all to
cinders with this the hunt became known
to all perhaps the church feared an
uprising from the people of yharnam for
a note in central yharnam reads when the
hunt began the healing church left us
blocking the great bridge to cathedral
ward as old yharnam burned to the ground
that moonlit night
as a result Herman's workshop was sealed
and closed with the scourge of the
beasts known to all perhaps there was no
need for secrecy anymore
the saw hunter badge comes to read badge
crafted long ago at the workshop attests
to one's prowess as a hunter of beasts
the workshop is gone and no group
recognises this meaningless badge at
this point the church retreats they
block themselves off in upper cathedral
ward and come up with a new strategy for
dealing with the scourge of the Beast
that is spreading throughout yharnam
eventually the workshop hunters would
disband and the church founded the
church hunter workshop in its place
Ludwig was the chief hunter of the
healing church which consisted of
hunters garbed in black and white the
black church hunter attire reads most
healing church hunters are elementary
doctors who understands the importance
of early prevention of the scourge
achieved by disposing of victims even
potential victims before signs of
sickness manifest themselves their black
attire is synonymous with fear and that
peculiar yharnam madness the black
church hunters job was clear remove any
sign of the scourge of the Beast even if
it hasn't manifested itself yet the fear
that it inspired in the citizens shows
most epic theatre award are deathly
afraid of the church the white church
hunters jobs were a bit different these
doctors are superiors to the black
preventative hunters and specialists in
experimentally backed blood ministration
and the scourge of the beasts they
believe that medicine is not a means of
treatment but rather a method of
research and that some knowledge can
only be attained by exposing oneself to
sickness their experimentation might
explain the monstrously large church
Giants who would have been particularly
useful in the fight against the beasts
Ludwig's great sword exhibits several
departures from the workshops design
suggesting that the church anticipated
much larger inhuman beasts on top of
this Ludwig took a much more overt
approach to beasts hunting nightly he
would embark upon central yharnam across
the Great Bridge to fight back against
the beasts but he was not alone the
population of central yharnam joined the
hunt as well swelling the ranks of the
hunters
Ludwig the first hunter of the healing
church once recruited he animates to
serve as hunters this hunters attire was
made for new recruits and has excellent
straightforward defense but not nearly
enough to allow an ordinary man to stand
any real chance against the beasts it
sounds like a very clever move as it
probably stopped the populace blaming
the church and likely formed more of a
us versus them mentality meanwhile in
Bergen Worth Master Willem had an
epiphany we are thinking on the basest
of planes what we need are more eyes
Willem took this very literally the
remaining students of Bergen worth
appear to have been transformed into
multi eyed fly like creatures and more
importantly Willem himself found an
umbilical cord of a great one which was
a very significant and powerful artifact
Provost Willem sought the court in order
to elevate his being and thoughts to
those of a great one by lining his brain
with eyes the only choice he knew if man
were ever to match their greatness used
to gain insight and so they say eyes on
the inside although no one remembers
what that truly entails it's difficult
to know exactly how Willem came across
or created an umbilical cord so we'll
have to go into that in another video
just know that he has one for now when
we encounter Willem he directs us to the
great lake the power of great bodies of
water is actually referenced in a few
runes great volumes of water serve as a
bulwark guiding asleep and an augur of
the eldritch truth overcome this
hindrance and seek what is yours the
lake and what lies within it hides the
truth rom the Bergen wolf spider lies
within and there's a lot we don't know
about her but I'll tell you what we do
know the Bergen worth spider hides all
manner of rituals and keeps our lost
master from us a terrible shame the
spider is certain to reveal nothing for
true enlightenment need not be shared I
believe this is what the vacuous part of
roms name refers to this creature is
somehow hiding the true nature of the
world and when you defeated you don't
need insight to see the world for what
it truly is the night moves forward the
moon descends and after killing rom we
have finally granted access to what
remains of yaha ghoul home of Michael
ash and his school of mensis the school
of mensis appears to have grown apart
from the healing church and the choir
there is little information on Michael
ash and his school but we can prove that
there was a split firstly Michael ash
uses the augur of a brightest a secret
right of the choir shared among the
high-ranking members of the healing
Church this suggests he was trusted with
this information and was once a sane
member of the church to prove that there
was a split between the healing church's
choir and the school we note clear signs
of distrust and fighting between the
groups imprisoned inside yahoo ghoul is
the corpse of a member of the choir and
inside the nightmare of mensis we find
who the official guide calls edgar choir
intelligence clearly the choir was
suspicious of what was going on in yahoo
ghoul with the school of mensis and
based on what we find there enya Huggle
it seems the choir had good reason to be
school of mensis were attempting to
commune with the great ones and they
succeeded as willem did they found an
umbilical cord we find four chords in
the game that allow contact with the
great ones and Michael Ashe had won this
court granted menses audience with mergo
but resulted in the still birth of their
brains as we know most great ones reside
in the Nightmare Realm and whatever
ritual they performed with this cord
ripped menses and its students into a
nightmare that's why you find the
lecture hall in the nightmare and that's
why there's hundreds of dead students
throughout Yahoo ghoul all wearing the
cage that appears to have delivered them
to their harrowing nightmare
Michael Ash's corpse provides a gateway
into the nightmare and we find him here
clearly insane wandering the halls
Michael ash believes that it's possible
to ascend towards becoming a great one
citing Ron as his example rom however is
not fully developed rather she has the
blood of their kin and let's just go
back to ROM for a second when you defeat
ROM Queen yharnam appears she's a -
Marion woman who has clearly suffered a
childbirth gone horribly wrong
she is linked to the nine
mayor of mensis to the ritual that Rahm
was hiding and she appears in this
nightmare looking up towards Margo's
loft where mojo and his wet-nurse reside
queen yharnam hails from the Tamarians
civilization that was in power long ago
and she was blessed with a child of the
great ones from the way she appears
outside mogo's loft it is clear that her
consciousness her spirit was pulled into
this nightmare as well even when you
encounter queen Janos real self in the
two Marian tombs the baby moe go screams
whenever you hit her and even when you
kill yharnam in the tombs it is clear
that she is not actually dead but her
horrific consciousness is only asleep
and it stirs in unsettling emotions her
consciousness seems to be showing up
here in the nightmare completely
separate from her physical form the same
thing is happening with you with my
Kailash with the great ones in the
nightmare with you you all exist in this
nightmare that mensis created so your
next question is which great one
impregnated yharnam with mojo all those
years ago I believe it is formless oedon
the great one Odin lacking form exists
only in voice to sight the fastest
evidence to present there's nothing in
the cradle after you defeat mojo and
Mogo himself the child has no form also
his cries are heard throughout your
adventure he exists everywhere
additionally mogo's wetness has no form
under those robes and also the women
that are impregnated when this blood
moon descends are all related to Odin
but we'll get to that in another video
when you defeat mogo's wetness you get a
message unlike any other that you've
received thus far
instead of prey slaughtered you get
nightmare slain you defeated a true
great one that's elevated its
consciousness to the nightmare realm and
the game is nearing its end however all
of this should make you think the
nightmare of menses isn't the only
dreamworld I've set foot in is it this
entire time I've actually been
journeying out from the hunter's dream
guided by lanterns that led me to mojo
and her wetness all of which is made
possible by gurmann and
stole travel to the hunters workshop in
the waking world and seek the truth
every great one loses its child and then
yearns for a surrogate the third
umbilical cord precipitated the
encounter with the pale moon which
beckoned to the hunters and conceived
the hunter's dream next to the cord is
the UH Nana mated doll take a hairpin
from this real doll and then pass it
along to the doll in the dream when you
give her the hairpin she sheds a single
tear which reads created from the
shining silver Dalt here this blood gem
is a quiet yet unfaltering friend that
continually restores HP the life essence
of a hunter perhaps this dolls creator
had wished for such a friend
albe it in vain it's clear that gurmann
called upon the great ones using an
umbilical cord similar to the manner in
which micolash did the great ones that
inhabit the nightmare are sympathetic in
spirit and often answer when called upon
gurmann lonely and lacking purpose after
the church had no more need for his
workshop must have called upon the great
ones a great one responded the pale moon
presence and imprisoned Germann within
the dream for while gurmann sleeps he
utters this rare piece of dialogue that
clearly shows he does not want to be
Lawrence Master Willem somebody help me
unshackle me please anybody I've had
enough of this dream the heart blocks
all sight Oh
[Music]
so for what purpose was the dream
conceived
well the doll tells us that countless
hunters have passed through here and all
of the graves tell us that as well and
Eileen and Jura both have dialogue that
is testament to that fact they talk
about how they've been through this
dream before as well so why are hunters
being sent through this dream unable to
pass away just forced to go out into the
world and kill beasts it becomes clearer
when you kill mogo's wet-nurse you
return to the hunter's workshop burning
down the dreams purpose fulfilled ago
the purpose of your dream and your hunt
appears to have been to slay a great one
three endings are presented to you
the first Gherman offers you a way out
of the dream he asks you to accept your
death for if you do then you'll awaken
in the waking world of yharnam and your
consciousness will be no longer linked
to the dream the trophy for this ending
reads you lived through the hunt and saw
another day the second option is to
reject gurmann he suggests that to do so
must be a decision caused by madness and
he pits his will against yours
to forcibly remove you from the dream
all the while he entreats you to accept
your death and be freed from this dream
if you overpower gurmann we meet with
the moon presence the bane that appears
to have conceived of this nightmare
just like the nightmare Mogo conceived
it embraces you and in the cutscene to
follow we see ourselves performing the
same role that gurmann did hosting the
dream likely a slave to the moon
presence or perhaps its surrogate child
guiding hunters throughout this dream in
an effort to slave other great ones the
trophy for this ending reads captivated
by the moon presence you pledged to
watch over the hunter's dream there's
one key thing you need to remember the
great ones are a race but there are a
race unlike any other each great one is
entirely unique and they do not
necessarily work together in fact from
the existence of the dream an almost
inclined to believe that the moon
presence is hostile towards other great
ones
in the third and final ending you
consume three umbilical cords and resist
the will of the moon presence you
overpower it and in the cutscene to
follow the doll cuddles the being you
have become you have ascended truly as
few have before you the trophy
description states you became an infant
great one
lifting humanity into its next child so
after the end of all this you probably
still have questions what is pale blood
why does the moon presence guide hunters
towards killing beasts and great ones
which ending is the good ending for all
this and more you need to be subscribed
to the channel I'll have another video
out soon analyzing the endings and from
here on out the channel should split
into three main parts there's going to
be the law hunting series where we focus
on one aspect of the law and really
figure it out there's going to be
prepare to cry which is my favorite
series it's a series where I tell the
story of a character within Blood Bones
universe and there's going to be things
you missed which are short enjoyable
episodes that showcase an area of the
game and tell you everything that you
missed within it the criteria for these
episodes is generally if I find
something I think I missed or something
I did miss then I included in that
episode so those are the three main
series we're gonna have there's also
going to be other videos of course but
those are the three main series I'm
still thinking of doing a video on
scholar of the first sin still haven't
played that but thanks for watching and
I'll see you guys next time bye bye
[Music]